und das vorhandensein solcher
marktreifer verfahren das ist die
voraussetzung dafür dass nun das
tierschutzgesetz auch greifen kann und
deshalb auch unser engagement in dieser
sache und sie wissen seit ich als
ministerin auch begonnen habe habe ich
dieses thema auf der tagesordnung aber
nicht einfach nur mit einer forderung
ließ sich gut anhört sondern mit einer
unterlegung dass das ganze auch stabil
ist und mit unserer forschungsförderung
haben wir wirklich maßgeblich dazu
beigetragen dass wir den ausstieg jetzt
auch gesetzlich festlegen können
und so wollen wir auch nicht einfach
enden damit mit einem verbot sondern wir
wollen den tierschutz auch weiter noch
fördern in diesem bereich derzeit
arbeiten alle marktreifen verfahren zur
geschlechter bestimmung im mai in einem
zeitraum vom 9
bis zum 14 tag sie wissen wird 21 tage
lang ausgebrütet und das ist bereits
eine deutliche verbesserung des
tierschutzes denn wie gesagt insgesamt
werden werden küken 21 tage ausgebrütet
aber ich sage auch das reicht mir nicht
für die lange sicht der den tierschutz
will ich weiter noch verbessern
und deshalb sage ich in dem gesetz auch
ganz klar die jetzigen verfahren sind
brückentechnologien brückentechnologie
die zum beispiel wenn wir schauen die
geschlechter bestimmung bis zum 13
die muss ende 2023 auslaufen
also wir sind verboten ende 21 das küken
töten in deutschland aber ich will die
geschlechter bestimmung immer optimieren
noch weiter vorverlegen
und deshalb will ich auch sagen hühner
embryonen im dürfen dann nicht mehr nach
dem sechsten brutal getötet werden
abgetötet werden sondern oder nicht mehr
ausgebeutet werden
sie kennen das wenn der hände aufstehen
also das heißt sie kennen das aber man
weiß ist wie das funktioniert wenn eine
henne von den eiern aufsteht und sie
nicht mehr bebrütet dann wird aus
auch nichts und es liegen
wissenschaftlich gesicherter
erkenntnisse vor dass sich das
schmerzempfinden erst ab dem siebten
brot tag entwickelt man sagt das ist
vollständig ausgebildet sei etwa oder
stärker ausgebildet sei dazu sagt auch
dr
schick etwas wenn wir am 15 etwa sind
und ich will aber noch was zu den
alternativen sagen die gibt es auch das
heißt neben der geschlechter bestimmung
im stehen weitere alternativen zur
verfügung
auch diese haben wir mit
millionenbeträgen gefördert von meinem
ministerium
und da geht es um die aufzucht
männlicher küken aus legehennen linien
also sehr wurden in deutschland jährlich
rund 45 millionen männliche küken
geschreddert genau das soll jetzt ein
ende finden ministerin aigner hat einen
gesetzesentwurf nun vorgelegt der bis
zum ende kommenden jahres ein verbot
zeigen sollte genau darüber möchte ich
jetzt sprechen mit dem tierschützer
friedrich mir zugeschaltet hermann
reichen diese neue gesetzesentwürfe die
frau klagt man jetzt vorgestellt hat in
ihren augen
also wenn ich mir das jetzt anhören was
frau klöckner gerade gesagt hört das kam
reichlich für wäre darüber das ist wahr
das erste ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
sie genau wusste wovon sie spricht
weil sie sagt zum beispiel marktreife
methoden die entwicklung von marktreifen
methoden würde abhängig sein ob das
tierschutzgesetz angewendet werden kann
oder nicht ja um himmels willen gilt das
tierschutzgesetz oder licht oder gilt es
nur wenn profis mit den tieren möglich
ist und hier hat die dame eindeutig
etwas missverstanden und das zeigt schon
in welche richtung das wieder geht man
möchte die massentierhaltung um jeden
preis erhalten man hangelt sich von
einem tierleid zum nächsten und ich kann
es einfach nicht feiern dass ein
rechtsbruch der in den letzten 50 jahren
um gescholten praktiziert wurde jetzt
gefeiert wird das man eigentlich etwas
macht was man schon vor 50 jahren hätte
machen sollen also da sind wir weit von
dem entfernt was sich die leute
vorstellen dass tiere nicht leiden denn
die ausbeutung von tieren hängt nun mal
mit dem leiden zusammen ausbeutung geht
nicht einvernehmlich
gibt es denn in ihren augen überhaupt
eine methode wie man jetzt trotzdem den
konsum an eiern der in deutschland und
dann vielleicht in deutschland nun mal
da ist verbinden könnte mit einer einer
methode die auch für die tiere dann im
besten sinne wäre ich habe die arge
zweifel ich denke das wichtigste ist
wenn die politik versagt wenn die
industrie kein interesse hat dann müssen
die verbraucher und verbraucherinnen
handeln und durch ihren konsum
regulieren es heißt weniger weniger
weniger alternativen nutzen nur so kann
man den druck aus diesem absolut
wahnsinnige massentierhaltung system
rausnehmen und ich möchte daran erinnern
dass das schreddern und vergasen von
typen ja nicht bei den männlichen küken
aufhört das hat vor klöckner offenbar
noch gar nicht gemerkt dass in diesen
industrie brütereien muss er dutzende in
deutschland gibt auch massenweise völlig
gesunde weiblichen tiere vergast werden
weil sie einfach zu viel produziert wenn
es wird gezielt überproduktion gemacht
um halt nicht das risiko sowohl risiko
zu haben dass man zu wenig produziert
und unsere undercover ermittlerin hat in
bayern vor zwei jahren selber bewiesen
wie zehntausende gesunde weibliche tiere
vergast werden
also man sieht diese branche ist nicht
bereit auch nur 1 mm nachzugeben die
politik ist entweder gutgläubig oder
steht dieser lobby gewehr bei fuß der
verbraucher ist gefordert durch seinen
konsum zu regulieren und das heißt eben
nicht jeden tag einen apfel auf den
tisch mehr nachrichten und breaking news
nur bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren